in today's this verse is that there are  summer internships and then there are  summer internships in Silicon Valley  this is a summer internship you know  what it's like right you pack up your  best clothes you find a cheap place to  live and you work at a place you hope  will look good when you get out of  college according to the National  Association of Colleges and employers  almost half of summer internships are  unpaid well that is Silicon Valley's  internships unpaid no way you'll get  more than five thousand dollars a month  interning at Yahoo and salesforce.com  about 4,600 a month at Intel and of  course you're hoping to impress the boss  enough so that you'll get a full-time  offer once you graduate at juniper the  average salary for interns who snag a  permanent job more than a hundred thirty  thousand dollars just starting off